Wie wirkt sich eine rein pflanzliche Ernährung
auf unser Körpergewicht aus?!
Ein internationales Forschungsteam hat genau
diese Fragestellung jetzt einmal genauer untersucht.
Zwar ist bekannt, dass durch Veganer Ernährung,
wenn man nicht darauf achtet, wichtige Nahrungskomponenten
fehlen können, Aber laut der Studie kann
eine vegane fettarme Ernährung tatsächlich
gesund sein.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Ob man Fleisch isst, sich vegetarisch oder
rein vegan ernährt, hat nicht nur etwas mit
moralischen Werten zu tun.
Denn nicht nur das Wohl der Tiere leidet unter
dem massenhaften Fleischkonsum, sondern auch
das Klima.
Eine große Studie hat erst vor kurzem gezeigt,
dass die fünf weltweit größten Fleisch-
und Molkerei-Konzerne für mehr Treibhausgas-Emissionen
verantwortlich als jeweils einer der größten
Ölkonzerne dieser Welt!
Wir hatten darüber ausführlich bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction berichtet.
Doch bei der Entscheidung für oder gegen
eine bestimmte Ernährungsform spielen natürlich
auch die Vor- und Nachteile für den eigenen
Körper eine entscheidende Rolle.
Und hierzu gibt es einen richtigen Dschungel
an Studien, die es gar nicht so einfach machen,
sich einen Überblick zu verschaffen.
Fachleute weisen darauf hin, dass bei einer
reinen veganen, also pflanzlichen Ernährung,
die Herausforderung besteht, den Körper mit
bestimmten Nährstoffen zu versorgen.
Da ist es also wichtig, sich im Vorfeld zu
informieren und beispielsweise reichlich Hülsenfrüchte
zu sich zu nehmen, um den Körper mit Eisen
zu versorgen.
Außerdem Lebensmittel mit zusätzlichem Vitamin
B12 - wie beispielsweise Frühstückscerealien
oder Hefeextraktaufstriche, die ja sowieso
das Vitamin B12 enthalten.
Doch dieser minimale “Aufwand” lohnt sich
wohl - nicht nur in Hinblick auf das Klima
und unsere Umwelt, sondern auch in Hinblick
auf unsere eigene Gesundheit.
Eine Studie, die jetzt auf der Jahrestagung
der “European Association for the Study
of Diabetes” vorgestellt wurde, bestärkt
dies.
Das Forschungsteam ist von der Organisation
mit der Bezeichnung “Physicians Committee
for Responsible Medicine (PCRM) “. Mehrere
tausend Ärztinnen und Ärzte haben sich hier
zusammengeschlossen und setzen sich unter
anderem für eine pflanzliche Ernährung.
Zudem kümmern sie sich um Alternativen zu
Tierversuchen.
Bei der aktuellen Studie hatten knapp 150
fettleibige und übergewichtige Erwachsene
mitgemacht: 16 Wochen lang ernährte sich
die Hälfte von ihnen vegan und fettarm.
Das Ergebnis ist eindeutig: Diese Teilnehmerinnen
und Teilnehmer hatten bei der abschließenden
Untersuchung deutlich an Gewicht verloren.
Zwei Drittel des verlorenen Gewichts bestand
dabei aus Körperfett.
Das Autorenteam schiebt dieses Ergebnis auf
die Veränderungen im Verdauungssystem.
Denn die Untersuchungen zeigten, dass die
Anzahl von gesunden Darmbakterien bei den
Veganern deutlich höher war als bei den nIcht-Veganern.
Dies begünstigt laut der Fachleute aber nicht
nur die Darmgesundheit selbst, sondern schützt
auch vor anderen Krankheiten wie etwa Diabetes.
Dazu Hana Kahleova, die an der Studie beteiligt
war: “Eine pflanzliche Ernährung mit reichlich
Ballaststoffen verändert die Zusammensetzung
des Darmmikrobioms zum Positiven, indem sie
die richtige Art von Bakterien ernährt”.
Konkret geht es um die Darmbakterien mit der
Bezeichnung “Bacteroidetes”, die vor allem
bei den veganen Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmern
zu finden waren.
Diese werden oft auch als “Schlankmacher-Bakterien”
bezeichnet.
Da sie die aufgenommene Nahrung nicht besonders
fein säuberlich auftrennen, ziehen sie weniger
Kalorien aus der Nahrung heraus.
Sie lieben ballaststoffreiche Lebensmittel
wie Vollkornprodukte, Obst und Gemüse und
vermehren sich bei dieser Art von Ernährung
mit rasanter Geschwindigkeit.
Ähnlich ist es mit der Bakterienart namens”
Faecalibacterium prausnitzii” - auch diese
leben von den Ballaststoffen, die in pflanzlichen
Produkten enthalten sind.
Diese Bakterien sollen nicht nur vor Darmerkrankungen
schützen, sondern werden auch mit einer Gewichtsabnahme
in Verbindung gebracht.
Konkret sollen “Faecalibacterium prausnitzii”
die sogenannte Inulin-Empfindlichkeit verbessern.
Auch bei Inulin handelt es sich um einen Ballaststoff,
der in bestimmten Pflanzen wie beispielsweise
Pastinaken eingelagert wird.
Im menschlichen Körper soll er eine gesunde
Darmflora fördern und die Verdauung aktivieren.
Die Bakterienart “Faecalibacterium prausnitzii”
ist somit wichtig für einen gesunden Stoffwechsel:
eine wichtige Voraussetzung für die Gewichtsabnahme
und die Reduzierung des Körperfett.
Weitere Studien sollen jetzt folgen, um die
fettarme vegane Ernährung mit weiteren Ernährungsformen
zu vergleichen.
Beispielsweise mit einer fettreichen veganen
Ernährung, aber auch mit der sogenannten
mediterranen Ernährungsform.
Mehr Schlaganfälle durch vegane und vegetarische
Ernährung!
Anklicken, anschauen und Clixoom nature abonnieren!
Da gibt es noch weitaus mehr Videos rund um
Natur und Umwelt.
Also unbedingt anschauen und abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!